[Music]
what'd he talk did anybody take pictures
of me yeah you know there was no faces
there was nothing and what it was was
baby was snoring the baby was a year old
she was fussing and she went to pick her
up from the video like this
and she bled a little bit then she
brought that back up nobody was there
right nobody was there to see when I
came down I saw her I would ahead thank
you break a nose you're going yeah so
she said that something Court and I
gonna meet up make the proof proof proof
I'm get on the phone right now 20
stories
[Music]
[Laughter]
like this is what I knew the next step
from here yeah because I had the
detective that arrested me because she
actually wanted to taste and he was
worth when seeker the same you know he
just stood there like yeah he's a bad
person I walk how do you know did you
arrest me you're so stupid you didn't do
a background check and you dumped a
background check I wouldn't be it might
not be good for your life
so call way you dumb lurch in my [__]
so I thought if we out of the way out he
was walking with them as a couple like
this is gonna work out for you police
bring carrots to a house to see her go
[__] crazy I never see a bunny in
whatever wrap it up their ass I just
kept saying Cathy tell about the cameras
up your ass you never told John about
those carrots when I pull about make
this
[Music]
nice listening no problem I'll take the
carriage you can roll nothing nothing
nobody could do that potato right you
know what the worst crime was they had a
drop to get off the next day they beat
them that's a dead be them in some stew
one man but this is your shirt oh she
won't ever look at me she would even
look at there was nothing they can do in
that know that that one I knew that
[Music]
that's the way to start a Monday
[__] Uncle Joe
Uncle Joe we hear dropping it you bad
mother [__] this Monday night what do
you got you got football
you got no baseball you got Dancing with
the Stars [__] all that you got your
uncle Joey we're going big tonight
[Music]
just like that motherfucker's 400 off
the bat what have you done lately what
have you done for your country that is
nice you see how we do it in we don't
[__] around it's Veterans Day we starts
for veterans and [__] these guys that
can't walk I mean the star for them will
go in deep tonight [__] cuz I'm a
sexy move like a stud like look at this
we got some perennial chocolate chump
it's an indica this is this [__] they
give you the [__] bring your dick
back when your wife lights it on fire
for [__] that Filipino maid didn't
say everybody wants to [__] a Filipino
maid so you start scratching an hour
later you follow me
[Music]
when you thought it was gonna be a
ho-hum night you think your hangout one
of your [__] friends micro dosing all
I've been micro dosing all day
suck my micro dose dick how's that one
for you micro doses if you ain't smoking
the heavy-duty you're slipping and if
you're under 18 hang up now you little
douche bags go play with Legos or
something you little [__]
I don't want your honor you're learning
tricks and [__] so they'd be a good
podcast tonight we got nothing this week
tomorrow night sold out next Wednesday
sold out so all we got is the podcast
all for you and [__] periscopes
and that's it we got tremendous weed we
got the last of the one I do weed this
is the bottom this goes to my favorite
[__] [__] right there oh this
is good just as yum-yum when you do the
bottom that [__] dust with
fingernails the fungi toe I got to cut
it and let Buffalo and I have a table
full of fungi dust no I thought about
putting it in here mix it up a little
fungi dust and some reefer my wife's got
that thing that my wife's got that thing
to keep up keep our feet soft so I take
it
potato weed from the different weeks but
it got stoned there's a [__]
didn't you smoke some of that cat
disease it's gone around
and my suicide right on the stage which
one I'm gonna give him the one-two the
last the one I do if there's two
partners in me I'll give you one of that
stuff
oh yeah I'll give you I'll give you a
little fun man let's get the party
started
[Music]
then giving them let me fill it up I
gave you a little half a [__] bolded it
son who the [__] do you think you're
dealing with on a Monday night and you
thought I don't know what I'm gonna do
tonight I'm kind of bored I had a rough
weekend [__] you if you came to the
shows and got them I love you whoever
threw the first chair tremendous mine oh
[__]
boy is strange and it's training eh I
hope you [__] have seen the
devil tonight Louie let's start with the
devil retreat hit now you can finish
your finish that's gonna change you
right away as you spit it out it changes
you that's the kind of weed I get it's
life changing
that's why Lee goes through changes I
told you that's the bottom half of the
killer never the Jew delivers weed it's
ugly
he's got that dungeon maybe like between
the daytime to keep the blog off
yeah those are baby ones a red one
[Music]
you ready Lisa let's do this [__] he's
like that [__] killer Lifetime movie
from prom queen to hooker Elin says get
over here [__] Jackyl bet she went
from the prom queen they're doing prom
to do a porno you ever see a little cute
girl with glasses here we go just do the
exercises gonna make sure that the belly
button is to spine push that all they're
[Music]
about to do now grab the [__] bar we
do it this is a process you two could go
to uncle Joey's bomb School 1-800 bucket
reservations right now no financial aid
available that's the one that's the one
that killed Medusa that's the one all
right there you go there you go right
there
there you go they go just hit that smoke
spit that smoke who cares about the
carpet who cares about the car to go for
that there you go [__] around somewhere
else that's the wheel of death right
there jack
[Music]
did it come out of here the water yeah
jesus christ almighty you said I gotta
deal with that's the bomb that killed
the lung right there [__] around you
know I'm saying you want you want to
keep your lungs never show up at the
Voodoo Lounge and then we clean them
with Clorox and the Clorox things for
the [__] thing so when you smoke the
weed the Clorox you it from Clorox to I
kill you it every way I can
you know Sam your lungs go down here how
good was that [__] Barnett Doug chase
the boy right through the part in the
case of mistaken identity
ha breaker with your 44
oh [__]
now the cigarettes we don't [__] around
here though yes what do you want to do
with those stars that I'm wolfy
this ain't no [__] charity night
tonight let's do some coconuts hit show
Co Coco are you ready for some Cho ko ko
ko' you don't need no seconds [__]
[Music]
here we go here we go with the Clorox
bleach gotta clean your blonde bond with
the Clorox beat bleach and then you
smoke the weed the weed of organs the
bleach goes into your system it's like
cocaine and reverse
[Music]
we want them you want to keep hanging
over your [__] friends at Starbucks I
smoked the joining of lemon twist today
go [__] yourself with smoking debt - you
understand me
I want your highball on my table I think
the one I drew is an eye patch for cuz
he smokes that [__] [__] weed from
Ventura Boulevard [__] no cuz we're
smoking death here and if you're not
gonna smoke death go hang out with these
other [__] mall mothers at the [__]
[Music]
oh he's only up to three he's got eat
n15 do not do that to do the tuna
it's [__] Monday out but elbows and
[__] that's it I want no drama you
[__] how many G so far we'll
just hold back
[Music]
9 o'clock at night you'll be ready for
the 405 will tell me I'll leave 7:45 No
well this looks like your [__] tomorrow
night that's all night in the car no
it's not that bad
we got to leave here 5:45 what do you
think it's to the 405 on the form so
seven o'clock Molly call Sam mommy call
Sam if mom and oberoi to the airport
with Sam in the neck relaxes you'd have
to come back you gotta go down and come
back on that trap it's the back let it
rock [__] youtube.com / c /
Joey Diaz is the place to be ten minutes
you [__] my books you know I love you
with all my [__] art without you I
haven't [__] nothing you follow me
it's you and me against them who's them
these [__] [__] changing Columbus
birthday [__] like that we'll all that's
left will the last American frontier
after us that said it's just a bunch of
kids walking around oh god got listening
to [__] yell [__] that [__]
we make our own Yelp you follow me ten
minutes youtube.com / sleep / c / Johnny
D is ten minutes